well if it isn't the reject nation its
Greg Alba over hair and it's cow I don't
mean over hair we just got back from
Buena Park which is about two hours away
from here especially with traffic we
went to see GV cinemas in Buena Park and
it was actually really fun though I mean
though DRI can be a little tiresome it
was so much fun going over there that
was Hana theater experience going on had
a total blast go in there and please
check out our vlog for it I'm gonna be
heading it over the weekend a lot a lot
a lot of footage but anyway because we
were gone we did not get a cast a
stranger thing season 2 trailer wrong
time but let's watch it oh yeah patient
add a shout out for Rosa Parra today
it's been a while since I said shout out
to you my girl
it's snowing yep reaction she has hair
nice she was happy to do that as she
[Music]
horses
[Music]
is happening it all leads back to you
[Music]
there's that
shoes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where's the king
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
that's sean astin yeah
[Music]
Sean asked
Oh badass now
[Music]
[Music]
I have chills I have seriously devil
chills right now oh so much goodness in
that trailer that's like such leaps and
bounds from what season one was just the
trailer alone I can tell us oh so much
good
what I love about their marketing I said
yeah says like stranger things and then
two in the back they're treating it like
it's a sequel yeah the last season oh
yeah and it feels that way like I feel
like I'm watching like an extended
sequel right now feels more like Goonies
actually in a lot of ways so I think
that's so cool having Sean Astin in
there cuz I saw him there I was like
holy crap they got acid himself to be in
this thing that's pretty awesome 11 with
her hair growing out she looks kind of
like that boy from Spy Kids a redhead
one when he has big curly hair all right
that's what I thought it was and I saw
her from a far away shot yeah I don't
know if you noticed the little girl
who's got the red hair yeah yeah oh she
says she's she's like a friend of the
little kids who she just moved to town
and she's kind of gotten wrapped up in
their whole craziness and there's like a
love triangle between her Lucas and
Dustin she's kind of like this little
girl love interesting and she's got an
older brother played by Jason from the
new doctor he's in this yeah he's the
new bully Oh is he in this Izzie yeah oh
cool
they're definitely focusing a lot a lot
more on will ya which I'm happy about
because ya know will was not really in
the last season he was like the integral
thing he was a central focus of finding
will will they or won't they will they
or won't
I remember after the first season when
the first season ended they had that
little flash where will looks in the
mirror and then I was like will is sort
of like the new 11 person to like you
know I mean they need 11 obviously and
she's in this I'm really excited about
what they're gonna do we have those
character and where this is gonna lead
this feels like an organic step in the
in the direction they want her to go
because a lot of the images were seeing
were teased at the end of season 1 oh
yeah you know there's like a giant
spider crawling over the city yeah like
that that was something I was ready T so
I was like they already had something
like this in mind even though it sees
someone wrapped up pretty solid yeah I'm
excited to see where they go with this
Winona Ryder looks like she's a nurse
now whoa hey hey yeah cats off kill you
I'll kill you I'll kill you I'm sorry
calm Paul Reiser's in this so he's
playing kind of a new doctor yeah but I
don't think he's quite the same as the
last doctor yeah it seems like there's a
little bit more inspirations to Winona
Ryder's character Joyce she is in a
relationship with Sean Astin who plays
oh okay yeah okay old high school
classmate or something of hers it feels
like they're gonna be taking a David
harbor's character in a different
direction too because like at one point
you see him he's like an impatient
outfit and they're they're like watering
him down and stuff so it looks like
there might be experimenting on him a
little bit and I'm interested what
they're gonna do with this with Steve's
character because it seems like they're
gonna make him a lot more likeable this
season he seems like a much better
person this time because the first the
first go it was like they just kind of
forced you to have to like him because
you didn't have a choice and yeah
whereas this when it's like no really
he's really a good guy I think they had
bigger plans for him or something and I
didn't think I don't think they expected
the audience to hate him as much which
says a lot about him as an actor like we
really hated you
yeah we did hate you Steven hated use
your real name right yeah and let's
assume that the actions a little more
happed up a lot of gunshots in this
trailer cool throw in the game I think
he throws it to a kid
yeah I love that it's coming out a few
days before Halloween and the seasons
centered around Halloween yeah I know I
don't know how I'm gonna like I'm gonna
have to try to milk this one because it
I just yeah I hated waiting for the
season the 27th to the 29th is gonna be
one of my busiest weekend for this video
shout-out to Rosa para Rosa para one of
our dearest friends over at patreon
sweet mother to Cassandra and a bunch of
other children too Rosa you constantly
give your heart to us on numerous levels
the more I get to know you the kinder of
a soul that I feel you are I gotta tell
you if it were up to me if you didn't
have a husband I would do stranger
things to you Rosa seriously thank you
I promise Cassandra I would do a shout
out for her on the Infinity Ward further
when it comes out thought it was coming
out this month but when it does come out
November 4 ragnarok that's my guess
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell follow Kyle Luhrmann
on the fan Theory YouTube channel and
please keep a lookout for our upcoming
vlog at the cgv feeder and Buena Park
haunted experience and I'm gonna be
going there every weekend once we're d-x
experience that's right we got to try it
out so keep a lookout for that vlog I'm
telling it's gonna be a lot of fun with
a lot of work on that